Hmm.
Hey, what's going on?
It's Bill Burr and It's time for the
Monday morning podcast for Monday,
March 27th, 2017 2017 fuck
a decades flying bike.
Yeah.
You know what? I'm the 2011, 1213.
Can somebody tell me that 14 was cool?
Vaguely remember 15 and
then 16 and you know,
I want to thank everyone who
whined so much about it last year,
the worst year ever. I mean, that
one's pretty vivid. Lot of crying,
lots of crying.
And I don't mean for the right reasons
like David Bowie and prince passing,
but you know, you know Hillary
losing and that type of shit a lot.
A lot of crying, a lot of whining. Um,
anyways, I uh,
okay.
I don't even know what
the fuck to tell you.
I've been a did being
fucking daddy daycare here.
You know what I did for the first
time we finally went out, right?
Me And d were going fucking
crazy. Cause you have a baby,
you have a little baby. Yeah. Have
a little lady. This is the thing,
if it's your first kid, you fucking
scared to death. You're like,
I can't take this thing outside.
It's going to get a bowler.
You get all fucking nervous, you know,
and then it's gotta get his
fucking immunizations and
all of that type of shit.
And he just let go neo. Who Do I
fucking believe here? Jesus Christ.
I'll tell you those fucking shots. This
is what I actually, I just sat down.
I was like, nobody who's ever been in
the medical field told me not to do it.
I've had comedians, high school friends,
a fucking actresses,
a bunch of non doctors have advised to go,
what am I not going to get her
fucking vaccinated for polio? No,
it's that what it is
in fish. Shut the fuck.
Do you even own a lab code?
All you're doing is scaring
the shit out of me. So anyways,
um, so we were, you know, you fucking
afraid. So finally we were just like,
all right, fuck this. We
got a Stroller, you know.
So we started taking
walks around the block,
but my block has like the shittiest
sidewalk. It's like a, you know,
the ground's all shifted out here.
There's tree roots pushing it up.
You have no idea when you just
walk down the street, you know,
you start pushing the strolling, you're
trying to keep the kid quiet, you know,
cause she finally fell asleep. It's like
I'm pushing my daughter up the street.
It's like fucking linked to liquid
nitrogen. I'm just trying to keep her,
I don't want to say I'll start
crying, middle of the street,
just going down the street,
waking everybody up.
And I guess they were already
awake. I Dunno. So, um,
we finally ended up going to
the mall. I had that experience.
I went to the mall with
my wife and my kid.
We pulled in at a take out a stroller,
take her out of the car seat,
put her in and start walking around
the mall. And I gotta tell you,
it was fucking awesome. I, for the
first time in my life, I get the mall,
I get it. You know,
it's for teenage kids when they're trying
to get away from their parents, like,
mom, just leave me alone,
whatever. With friends,
that era before you have a license
really. And you can't really go anywhere.
You just need some sense of
fucking freedom. And it's for what?
After you become a parent,
you have to get out of the fucking
house into some sort of controlled
environment where there's enough God
damn people that you don't have to worry
about anybody snatch and your
goddamn kid, you know. Um,
so we walked around and uh,
just had a great fucking time,
was like the perfect day and uh, you know,
neo was all excited to be
out because uh, you know,
women just to have Jesus the shit
they go through being being the guy,
it's the best. I swear to
God it's why they fucking,
I think it's why they make our
lives so god damn miserable is they,
they see how easy it is.
And the thing is is we don't realize
how easy it is cause we've only been us,
you know what I mean? How long
it takes them to get ready.
Okay.
Do you know how long it
takes me to get ready now?
I've got a fucking shaved head. I
mean I don't even have to do anything.
You could literally hose me off in
the backyard and I could, you know,
I'd be ready in like seven
minutes, easy, seven minutes.
Cause I always got to run around and
find my cell phone for like five of those
minutes. But you know, if I,
if I actually was organized and knew
where all my shit was, I could be,
I could be writing like
three minutes. Um, anyways.
Yeah, they go through all of
that shit. You know what I mean?
You gotta breastfeed, they gotta, they
gotta they gotta pump all of that crap.
I don't have to do any of
that. You know what I mean?
So she was going fucking
nuts dealing with, um,
everything that nature put on her.
And she finally had to get out of the
house and it's the happiest I've seen her.
We walked around, had a
great time. You know what?
They haven't malls now this is second
mall I've been to that they have like a
Tesla, um, store. Like
you can go and like,
who the fuck just goes to the mall
and buys a car? You know what I mean?
You go there, you buy sunglasses,
right? A fucking Hula Hoop, whatever,
whatever it is, you buy it, buy a
car. So I, you know, I can't resist.
I got to go in there, right? And I'm
like, what's the deal with this thing?
Zero to 60 what do you, what are you
2.5 the guy's like 2.3 that's amazing.
I was up in San Jose.
The Guy told me 2.5 you shaved off
in another two hundreds of a second.
And I'm like, all right. So I get
four adults in there and he goes,
you can get five.
And I go and I'm still going to
go zero to 60 in 2.3 seconds.
It doesn't make any sense. All
that weight. What am I up to there?
Oh 2.93 and he goes, yeah,
probably two six. It's like,
what are you basing that on?
Other than the fact that you
want to make a commission?
What am I basing mine on? I don't
fucking know. So he goes, all right,
let's take a look at this over. I go,
dude, I just bought a car. I love it.
I'm not going to buy a car and we tell
you right now, but I just want to see,
you know, if I got the car that I wanted,
what this thing's going to cost me,
right? So I I go give me the one
with the motor, the all wheel drive.
Alright, I went black.
I didn't want to get the black interior
cause it's hot as shit out here, right?
So the guy goes, do you want the fucking,
the full moon roof and everything?
I go, dude, look at me. Oh I'm
almost an albino and I have a shade.
Had DD fucking and he goes down all
the tents, crazy on it. And I said,
all right, put it on the
fucking car. What do I care?
I'm not buying this thing right. Give
me the best you know, best tires,
best rims, best, best fucking
everything. Then they had this thing,
oh know for five grand when you get on
the highway kind of drives it kind of
helps you. And I was like, dude,
why would I buy a car like this?
And have something else dry. I want to
drive it. I don't need that shit. Right.
So that I didn't get everything
else I got in in the end.
I took a picture of it. I forget
how much it costs. Ah, fuck.
I don't need the exact number in the end.
You know what it costs
hundred and $52,000.
Okay.
Oh fuck. And what kills me.
Someone's going to go to the mall and
buy one of those hundred 52,000 fucking
dollars. I just wish they looked cooler.
I love the fucking tires and
everything and there's is, you know,
if you get the right tires and rims
and shit really helped that car and the
front end definitely looks better,
but I dunno man, you don't,
it looks like it looks like
that for two a portion.
It's ugly as shit had Panamera
whatever that, you know,
you don't think like always
try to do that in like the uh,
the car commercials will, they have
a two door car. They have the dad,
then he has the baby and then he grabs
the bumper and he turns it into a four
door car. Like, Oh wow, this is like a
sports car, but it's a four door sedan.
No it isn't. It's a four
door sedan and it won't,
but that's trying to be a sports
car and then it becomes ugly.
That's why I liked the Mercedes,
the BMW in the jet and the Jaguars
because they still look like cars,
like four door sedan. Then you step
on the gas. It's like, Oh shit,
look at this. Who Knew I'm
aren't talking about here.
Anyway, so we ended up having a, a a
great time and uh, I walked by the, um,
the fucking split stories, that
thing, whatever, whoever, uh,
the one that looks, looks like the
letter h, it's not Nike or Adidas,
it's the other one is the one that
fucking Steph curry has an in the window
there, these ugly ass basketball shoes.
And I looked in and said curry threes.
Yeah,
dude, gun to your head.
What do you like better than
the Colby eleven's or the curry threes?
I don't know. Do the curry threes,
you know, with a fucking Chris
pair of jeans and a Hoodie
over we you chain on the outside.
Okay.
Male fashion needs do Jordan threes.
All right. Jordan trees. Okay.
With the pair of Joe's
jeans. All alright. And,
and a button down in a new Yankee dude.
New Yankee had two and a slice of pizza.
Does it get any better?
Playing playstation on the TV and
inside down this cowboy stadium.
Crazy ultimate bachelor party dude.
A pair of fucking Jordan nine
right jeans cuffed creased with,
with an Abercrombie and
Fitch v-neck t shirt,
extra soft
play play station with the slice of
pizza in a fucking cowboy stadium.
Does it get any better than that dude?
Okay,
I'm sorry. I don't know what it is.
I like sneakers and I've actually been
buying some, I just liked the old ones.
Like I got a pair of shell toes and I
got a pair early eighties fucking Adidas
like high tops. Like I liked that
shit. Like, I dunno what the,
when fucking Picasso started designing
these goddamn things, it's like,
it makes no sense. Um, I'm going
to get in trouble for this shit.
I'm going to say later on in this podcast
that I didn't know what the fuck to
tell you. I get some shout outs to do.
I never give shout outs. Right. And um,
I just had a bunch that would
just pile it up and I'm like,
I finally got to give out some
fucking shout outs and then,
but I just never get around to them.
It's extra work. I never give a fuck.
But then finally somebody tipped
me over the fucking edge. Right.
Laura is, I gotta gotta I gotta give
this person a shout out. All right,
so first of all, let's, let's get the, uh,
let's get the opener and
the feature out of the way.
A shout out to Eric and Bose for
hooking me up with some of those Bose
headphones. I was bitching about, um,
people being loud in, uh, you know,
on the plane and shit. And by the way,
this is not so I can get more free shit.
I don't want any more shit. I'm getting
rid of Shit. If you give me free shit,
I'm going to give it away or I'm going
to send it down to fucking goodwill and
it's going to end up in a truck that
sits in a warehouse and they're going to
dump it and then, Oh shit. So I don't
want any shit, you know, and nice email.
Hey Bill, like you stuff, that's just
fine. Okay. But if somebody did send me,
you gotta say thank you. Right. All
right. Shout out to Eric at Bose and then,
uh, James Shotwell. Um, I
did this thing this weekend,
um,
rock against ms where I got to give
an award to a Richard Pryor's widow,
Jennifer Pryor, and uh, you know,
Richard suffered from that disease and
of course he turned it into comedy and
set out the disease, actually slowed
him down so he could live longer. Um,
which is really fascinating
that, that's probably true. Um,
and anyways, James Shotwell was
down there doing, I don't know,
working like the sound, I've got to
see all these fucking killer bands,
these amalgams,
like fucking Alison chains with
Nancy Wilson from heart coming out,
crushing it. Then she
brought her new a band out,
road case royal and they fucking killed
it too. She's a, she's still a beast.
I got to see Steven Adler
play with an all star band.
He played um, the hell did he
play? He played, uh, the Ramones.
I want to be sedated and then I got to
stand at like 10 feet away from him.
I got to watch him play.
Welcome to the jungle and rocket
Queen and see all this subtle,
all these little subtle things
that he's, first of all,
I get to see all the genius drum parts
that fit so perfectly to that song.
And then just the different ways that
he played them. Um, you know that part,
you know, so, uh, no, no, no, no, blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah. It's really,
I always thought he was on both times.
He's just riding on the floor, Tom.
And on the second scenario
it comes over with the Flint.
That's that little shit when you're
a drum nerd like me. I'm like,
that's how we fucking plays it. And I
got the, of course he was Cooley Shit,
you know, he's such a fucking
great guy, man. Had, you know,
a couple people were there that had MSC,
let him fucking sit like right
behind them while he played.
When he finished playing, he came out,
he high fived everybody
in the front row do.
We were at the La Theater in
downtown La and it was um,
okay.
I guess it was a theater was
designed by Charlie Chaplin. Okay.
And when you walk in in the foyer,
there's a picture of Charlie Chaplin
walking in the night at first opened with
Albert Einstein. And uh,
of course I missed that photo.
Somebody told me it was there,
but downstairs they have this kid's
room that still has the original paints.
So they say don't touch the walls.
And of course it's all these
creepy fucking drawings.
Like being a kid was so
fucking scary back then.
All these creepy drawings of
clowns and horses and shit. And um,
someone was trying to claim, and I
refuse to believe that this is true,
that they, that's where you brought
your babies when they cried.
And if they got really loud, they
had these little like cabinets,
you just opened the door and you put
the baby in, you closed the door.
It's like even downstairs
they could still hear it.
I refuse to believe that that's
true. But, um, I ended up,
I call hosted it with Craig Gas,
who that guys impressions of fucking
unbelievable man is Sam Kinison is Gene
Simmons, Sebastian Bach. And he's
hung out with all of these guys.
So he has all these unreal stories
and he does dead on impressions of Jim
Florentine was there. Um, it was
an amazing fucking night. So,
um,
thank you to Nancy sail for putting that
whole thing on and I'll do it any year
that they want. And
then lastly, but Lezley
um, got it. We got a,
actually I got a request from
somebody who says that she's a fan,
a lady fan of the podcast
that my stand up, but a,
what she requested I
guess is already over. Ah,
she's trying to be, uh,
in next year's sports illustrated
swimsuit, Lisa Marie Jafta.
But the voting's already
closed. So I don't know.
I don't know if it was real or not.
I immediately didn't believe
that it was a real email.
And then she sent a video golf. Now,
seriously, I know you're a bald,
middle-aged content, but I
actually liked your stuff.
If you could send your listeners
over to vote for me, you know,
maybe I could get in the issue
next year. And uh, I dunno,
that's such a weird world.
You know what I mean?
You don't need that fuck myth about that
world was one time Nia had been watched
this fucking thing about
it and they had this creep
that was like the Goto guy and
he called himself uncle Terry.
Anybody who's not your uncle ladies,
anybody who's not your uncle.
And he says, just call me uncle so
and so. Yeah, he's trying to fuck you.
He's a fucking,
this guy was one of the creepiest fucking
people I've ever seen in my God damn
life. Um, so anyways, my apologies.
The voting is already fucking over,
but I don't even know if this,
I don't even know if it was real to
be honest with you, but you know what?
I'm a middle aged bald man and I that's
wanting to believe that that's true.
Is it? That's really all I have.
Um, and speaking of swimsuit models, oh,
la Billie fat tits area's been fucking
doing great on the elliptical of back at
it, man. I'm back at it. I fucked up
last night and had a glass of booze,
all the booze one last
night I just added a glass,
which is probably considered a triple
in any fucking hipster bar. But, um,
I was going to go to bed. I
wasn't gonna have it, you know,
I've been doing good. I stopped
eating at five and 1130. You know,
Nia had come home. I was hanging out
with my daughter, the whole nightmare.
She was a riot. She was
a riot. Jesus Christ out.
She had two apocalyptic fucking
diapers yesterday. That was just like,
it's just like really, I don't think,
I don't think I, I don't think I,
we've bought enough provisions
to ever get this fixed again.
So, um, she came home late and,
uh, and I was just going to go to bed
and I kept playing that mental tennis.
Should I have a glass? Don't
have glass, try to lose weight.
Should I have a glass? Don't. And then
finally the booze was just looking like,
come on. You know what the booze was like?
It was like Jimmy the gent, you know,
after they fucking did the
lift, one's the highest.
However you say the bottle
is just over there and going
[inaudible] and Henry comes
walking in. So I add one.
So I dunno. Um, it like one 80, 1.2,
and I've just been in the 80s. I
hate being in the 80s. That's one.
That's when I just,
and when I shift my weight around on the
couch just to go reach for the remote,
you just feel the role's going
home on the side of you. You know,
I don't know how people do it.
I don't know how you just walk
around being a fucking fat body.
I don't know why you tolerate that.
You got one fucking life and you knew,
you know God damn well
in the back of your head.
You don't know where you go after this.
Okay. Let's say best case scenario,
you get reincarnated. All right?
Cause the whole heaven health thing,
it's the same thing every
day. After a while it's,
it's not even gonna have any value. What
are you like me on fire again? Okay,
what does it, another perfect day. Oh boy,
you're going to be like those
teenagers at the mall. Oh God,
I'm so bored. Right? Um, best case
scenario, you get reincarnated.
The fucking odds that you're going to
come back again as a human being. I mean,
you know, if you can come
back as a fucking mouse or
some shit, like, you know,
fucking run around almost
having a heart attack. His,
some reptile is slowly tracking
you getting eaten alive. You know,
this is the best she got. So you can
fucking sit here and become a tub of shit.
You don't want you, you owe it to
yourself. So this is what I've been doing.
This has been the breakfast of a freckled
champion. Um, every morning I wake up,
go do to do dude, and I go
out to the garage and, um,
what do I do? I go to, um,
I go in the fucking elliptical as my, um,
my rotator cuff is slowly getting
better. Today. I did some lady pushups.
I was going to do 20. I was like, don't
push it. Stop to 12, stopped at 12,
just trying to keep the fucking man
tits from sagging down into my navel.
Um, and I do like a half hour on the, uh,
on the elliptical and then it come in
and for breakfast I have one of those
little oranges and I
have a, a, a poached egg
and that's it. And then I have a
banana between there and lunch.
And then for lunch I have some
sort of protein, a, you know,
maybe with a little bit of bread, some
sort of Ghana. I know breads the enemy,
go fuck yourself. Um, it's the
only bread I have. And then
I don't know what the fuck it is.
Then I have a protein with the salad
at four protein with the salad at six,
and then I'm done. Then I just drink
waters for the rest of the night.
In theory, unless the fucking
Jimmy, the jet moment happens.
And I get fucked over. Um, anyways. Uh,
so I have to do this shit. I gotta
get my ass back down. I can't,
my birthday's coming up in June. I'm
going to be 49 fucking years old,
which I'm actually pretty, I'm all
right with it. Once you have a kid,
you kind of are right with being old.
You're like, other than that, yeah. Yeah.
And I'm 47. I don't have a kid.
I'm just going to die alone.
I'm going to be 49 and there's no fucking
way I'm going to be in the one 80.
So it's just not going to happen.
I'm telling you right now,
I am going to be one 72 my fighting
weight, where the hell I want to be.
My shoulder's going to be healed.
And I have a bet with Paul Versey
that when I'm 70 years old,
I'm going to be able to do 10 pull ups.
And if I don't get this
rotator cuff fixed, uh,
I'm going to be fucked because all
I keep thinking about is Jordan,
when he came back on
the wizards, you know,
and that was the first time you really
saw drop off in his playing level.
Cause not only was he gone for
three years, he didn't really play.
And when you stop, that's when you're
fucked. That's what I've learned.
Trying to get it back. It's, it's
hard. It's really fucking hard.
Although,
although Dee del Ray who crushed it in
San Jose del Ray in San Jose told me he's
doing sets of 20 fucking pull-ups.
I've never done 20 pull
ups in my life straight.
I think the most I ever I was able to
do is I just can't get past like 16.
He's 51 years old. Can do 20 pull
ups, sets of 20. So there's hope.
There's always hope.
Is this like an inspirational podcast
bill used to shit on stuff. All right.
I will. Um, but I, I can't, I can't,
I'm jabbing up. I'm having, you know,
I've gotten such so little material
I have on a daughter. I thought like,
all, fuck, here we go. My whole
act is gonna fucking change, man.
And it's been so awesome. You
know, what am I going to do?
Talk about how great it is somehow get
you don't really do as I, I should. I,
I pretty much in my act,
I just shit on people that talk
about how difficult parenting is.
You know what I mean? I'm not
saying, you know, it's not,
I'm not walking around sleepy as shit
all the time, but you know, come on.
Okay.
You know, go watch that
fucking movie. I tell.
Told you to watch where they torture
that kid that plays the violin.
That guy from peaky blinders is in it.
Anthropoid go watch that fucking thing.
Watch what those people went through
and tell me that being a parent is hard.
Um, anyways, sorry. Plowing
ahead. Oh, what happened?
Where do I start? Do I talk F1
do I talk about the Celtics?
Do I talk about the Bruins
playing for their play off,
fighting for their playoff lines?
Let's talk Bruins and I'll do a little
advertising here with the Bruins.
Fucking 84 points. We lost
four fucking games in a row.
We just won one of those
goddamn games. We are now,
we will like all the way up to like,
I think a fourth seat at one point or
a fifth c. We are now an eighth seat.
Okay.
Toronto is ahead of us. I heard
that goaltender got hurt though.
Um,
where the fuck is it? I had this
goddamn standing sweat. Do I? What?
Did I deal with it anyways?
Okay.
I Dunno. Well, we, we got a huge Wayne,
thank you to Riley Nash for those two
fucking huge goals against the island is
we got the predators on Tuesday and then
we played this Stass is a big fucking
Boston team week. Dude.
You're going to the BS versus Stass
show them against the predators,
dude. Um,
and I'm going to go out on a limb and
say we kind of have to win both of those
fucking games or hope everybody
beneath is just keeps losing
unreal. Unreal. This is the
third year in a row. We're just,
the bottom's fallen out. But you know
what, I slowly see improvement though.
And I can see how this could
be a team that could, uh,
actually score a ton of goals
in the future. You know,
I saw on their website
today the up, you know, the,
the frozen four is happening
and uh, we got like,
we have four prospects in the
frozen for this year. So who knows.
I mean the frozen for versus getting HL
is a big fucking leap. But who knows,
who knows? Maybe there's
an, there's an Austin, uh,
with the fuck's his name Matthews in
there. Who knows. Um, but anyways, dude,
speaking of that shit, speaking of the
frozen four, what about the final four?
I barely paid attention, man, cause
I've been running around, you know,
being a dad and everything, but I,
every time I would just like, you see,
you heard me going, Duke lost,
then I'm like Kansas Lost
Kentucky, lost the final fours.
I remember verbally telling me was
it's North Carolina, understandable,
South Carolina Gonzaga. And uh,
I forget who the other team
is. Basically, there's no,
everybody's bracket is fucked at this
point. If your bracket isn't fucked,
if there's somebody out there
that actually picked this
year's final four in the
NCAA,
you that don't know shit about fucking
basketball and just guessed or your dad's
in the mob and something's going down
this year because just everybody's out of
it. Um, I don't know who
I'm going to vote for.
Okay.
Gonzaga South Carolina.
My teams would Duke or Kansas
and I was always liked UCLA.
Um, and they all got, UCLA
got fucking knocked out.
You know what annoyed me that day? I was
walking down the street and you know,
cause all the bandwagon fucking UCLA fans,
all of a sudden everybody's
rabid out here. You know what?
I was wearing a Bruin sweatshirt and
I'm walking down the street and this guy
goes, hey, goes hates UCLA
Bruins, not Boston Bruins.
And I just laughed at him. Ed, you guys
are good this year. He's like, yeah,
we are. And walked away. And
I was like, wait a minute.
That was at the car wash and
I fucking looked it up. Like,
who was the Bruins first?
And it was like the UCLA basketball team
was around before the Boston Bruins,
but their first year and
like 1918 or something,
they were the UCLA cubs and then the
next year they switched to the grizzlies.
And in like 1928 they joined.
I don't know what there was the
pack something pack 10 pack 12 Oh,
I don't know what the fuck it was
back then. Pack eight I have no idea.
But like there was some team from
Montana that was already the grizzlies.
In 1928 they switched to the UCLA Bruins.
However at the Boston Bruins
were in 1924 all right,
so all due respect to coach wooden,
all due respect to the UCLA program. I
actually liked the school and everything,
but when it comes to that Bruin
Shit, go fuck yourself. All right.
We were there first. Okay,
CIF, stand the fuck down.
It's a different sport. It's
a pro sport. So relaxed,
you know, you know bad.
I've been replaying that in my head that
I wished that I had that information.
You know, I wish they were in the
final four and I would've actually,
I'm such an argumentative con.
I would actually fucking maybe drive
over to Westwood and gets some air quote
lunch and just walk around with that
shirt. It's like, it'd be like, ah,
Nike crazy. Hey, no gay history,
no history. You know, like, like
I'm the fucking the sports guru.
Like I just didn't look that shit up
cause some guy was a contemplating of the
car wash. Um, all right, let's
do some reads here for this week.
Youtube channel announcement. Oh
yeah, I gotta do that too. All right.
They Internet privacy. Oh, these
are the reads for this week.
This is the shit that people sent
in. Oh, here we go. Wink. Everybody.
W I n Fucking C wink.
Finding a new wine is tough. Yeah.
Especially if it's shit faced.
That's why I've been telling you
all about our sponsored club.
Debbie had club Debbie and I getting
drunk. He can't, I'm not praising.
It doesn't count.
And how they make it so easy to get
wine personalized to your palate and
delivered right to your door. And here's
a little update for you. Clip, Yeti,
fight, tear and fight and Terry everywhere
out there, every there in the trees,
man is now called wink, spelled w. I n. C,
a new name and improved look.
But here's the important part.
It's the same amazing wine company
introducing you to new wines.
You'll love wink works directly with wine
makers and offers and growers from all
over the world to create delicious
wine and deliver it right to your door.
Winks 100% satisfaction guarantee means
if you don't like a bottle they send you
that. We'll price it with the
bottle you love. No questions asked.
If I was a fucking
alcoholic, which I might be.
That is the loophole right there. How
much of the bottle you get to finish?
Yeah, I didn't like it. Send
me another um, you know,
just get sent random bottles. Wait,
does personalized wine membership that
recommends wine specifically for you?
Based on the results of your
Palette and profile quiz,
you can also rate the wine you receive
from wink. So they'll learn about, yeah,
they'll basically figure out what you
like and then you always be having a great
bottle of wine. Then you start boots
and like fucking Ernest Hemingway.
The best part is Winc is offering
my listeners $20 off right now.
When you go to to try wink,
winz.com/bar they'll even cover
the shipping. Think about that.
Yeah,
they get done. You'll get fine
wine personalized to your palate,
delivered right to your door Winc and
get $20 off plus complimentary shipping
right now when you go to try winc.com
that's try winc.com t r y w I n c.com/bar
oh look who's back. Lo coups
back. It's our old friends,
old zip.
Are you hiring? Do you
know where to will are you?
Do you know where to post your
job to find the best candidates?
Posting your job in one place isn't
enough to find quality candidates.
If you want to find the perfect hire,
you need to post your job on all the
top job sites and now you can with Zip
[inaudible]
screwed up.com you can post your job
at 200 plus job sites including social
media networks like Facebook and the
Twitter, all with a single click.
Find candidates in any city or
industry nationwide. Just post once.
You can't and watch your qualified
candidates roll into all zip,
Dara. It is easy to use interface. No
juggling emails or calls to your office.
Quickly screen candidates, rate
them and hire the right person fast.
Find out today why ZipRecruiter has
been used by fortune 100 companies,
not 500 fortune 100 this is the top 100
companies of all time and thousands of
small and medium sized businesses.
Everybody's using it and right now my
listeners can try jobs on ZipRecruiter for
free by going to
ziprecruiter.com/burner
at ziprecruiter.com/
[inaudible] one more time.
Try for free. Go to zip
woo.com/burp
all right. Dollar Shave Club. Dude,
you like shave and you've faced.
Do you not want to cut it?
Apple I got to raise is for you.
There's no reason to use cheap disposable
raises or pay ridiculously high prices
kid for some gimmicky thing that's got
a laser pointed in 17 fucking blades
there. A make us smarter choice and
joined Dollar Shave Club. All right?
What are you doing? They're overpriced.
You'll always knew they were.
It's a piece of fucking plastic
was sharpened aluminum minute.
Should it be $90,000 wouldn't it be
great if they just delivered it right to
your fucking door or this thing offers
that service before dollar shave club?
It was, I just settle that shit.
Okay? I said it my own way. All right.
Get a clothes,
mutes shave every time and you can't
beat the convenience or the price of the
club. If you haven't tried dollar
shave club yet, you're missing out.
It's an amazing shave and affordable at
an affordable price. There's no smart,
smarter choice in the market right now.
They're giving away a one month trial
of any razor for only a dollar with free
shipping, and after that,
it's just a few bucks a month.
There's no longterm comp commitments.
This is a one night stand.
No hidden fees. You get the door, man,
five bucks you're in and you
can cancel whenever you want.
You know you can go bar hopping a get one.
Get your $1
trial@dollarshaveclub.com slash bird.
That's dollar shave club.com/burr.
Um, all right, helix.
Helux this is the last one. Oh God,
I love that they're making the copies
shorter and shorter for me. You're unique.
You're special. You're your own snowflake.
You don't walk like anyone else talk
like anyone else ship Chet or I always
thought, oh, it sounds like
that drill sergeant shit to me.
Remember that I'm going to teach you.
I'll have your mother's heart out pair.
Oh, I'm going to teach you
how to walk. Talk, check,
check my car. Um, you don't
want like anyone else.
You don't talk like anyone else
who's asleep like anyone else.
So why is your mattress one size fits all?
Because they truly customize me.
I trace will cost you five to $10,000
until now will for $10,000 for a fucking
mattress. I just refuse to
believe that that's true.
That should come with a lady giving you
a fucking hand job right before sleep
did go to helix.com helix answer a few
simple questions and they'll run a three
d biomechanical model of your body through
their proprietary algorithms they've
developed with the help of the world's
leading era Gomix and biomechanics
experts. The results. Why
don't you stretch a little?
You twist it up.
Count the fact that they got to sit there
and act like you're in the star wars.
The result, the most comfortable
mattress you've ever slept on.
You could also stretch everybody if
you stretch and then get one of these
mattresses. I think you're going to
be good. Go get a massage. You know,
drink some fucking water.
Okay,
10 grand for a mattress.
Okay.
Just have some fucking Asian lady
walk on your back a little bit.
Save some money.
Helix customers report at 30030%
improvement in overall sleep quality.
And it has to be an Asian
lady. Okay? Cause that dainty,
you can't get one of those American, we
can't get some white woman, you know,
you any, any other race, they're
going to be too far unless they're,
they're not gonna be old enough to
be in there. You know what I mean?
They get you going to
be too God damn dense.
They can be full of fucking
growth hormones and that
they're going to break it
back.
Okay?
That is an exclusive, dainty Asian lady.
I just thought about
that. I've never seen any,
any footage of a white lady
walking on somebody's back.
You just feel like I ride around,
get up, get up. All right.
Your mattress arrives at your door in
about a week and shipping is 100% free.
He looks, uh, and for couples, they
customize each side of the mattress.
That's why everyone from GQ magazines
to Forbes are talking about Helix,
last heloc sleep, customizing
both sides of your mattress.
I can't tell if that's gonna make
your relationship happier or it's the
beginning of the end. Oh God, I
don't even like the way he sleeps.
It'll be great.
Then I just want to test out what it'd
be like to sleep a different bed with
them, but still be in the same bed.
That's why everyone from GQ magazine
to Forbes are all talking about helix
sleep. Alex, uh, you have
100 nights to try it out,
and if you don't love it,
they'll pick it up for free,
rose and gave you 100%
refund. No questions asked.
We don't even want to know what that
stain is. We're not going to ask you.
Go to Helen's sleep.com/bar and get
$50 off your order. That's helix,
sleep.com/bar Heloc, sleep.com/. Burn
all right, there you go. Just like that.
We're done with the advertising we've
done with the advertising and we're on the
other side of, of the half hours.
We're going to do traffic on the sixes.
Anybody out on the four oh five, you
might want to get yourself a helicopter.
There's a lot of traffic.
Everybody slowing down,
watching somebody change
a tire. Um, anyways,
let's talk some F1 action. Did anybody,
did you watch the Australian grampy
grampy Grand Prix down in Melbourne,
Australia? Uh,
it was a great fucking race and it
lived up to the hype that this year the
Ferrari's, we're going to be good.
And I've only watched
this sport for one season,
so I don't know shit
about it all. He knows.
Last year it was all about the
Mercedes team, Louis Hamilton,
Nico Rosberg, you know, they had
the whole days of thunder. You know,
I'm the guy who's been around
the block on the other. Fuck I'm,
I'm the Tom Cruise Guy,
somebody fucking Robert
Duvall and everybody else,
which is watching last year. And if
those two guys didn't hate each other,
it would have been fucking boring as
shit because basically every race was
erased to the first corner.
Whoever got there first was just driving
through clean air and the cars were so
equally matched, nobody
could catch up with somebody.
You basically had to fuck
up or your car died. Um,
so all the exciting racing was
for like, you know, fourth, fifth,
sixth place or whatever, three psychos
going after it for the last, you know,
championship point as they say, you know,
back in 10th place. That was exciting.
But up front it was just Lewis
Hamilton or Nico Rosberg just,
just doing laps was, you know,
Kinda got a little boring.
So this year they were
talking about how, um,
Ferrari was very quiet, eerily
quiet during the off season,
working on their, their,
their suspension and the engine and
all that type of shit with the new
regulations, whatever the fuck they are,
I don't know what they are and that they
were gonna make a serious challenge for
, uh, against Mercedes issue.
So the fucking race starts
and, uh, the Australian Dude,
I already forget his name. Uh, Rico
Rican Berg. I have no fucking idea.
Like eventually I'll, I'll get these
people's names down. Ricky rocket,
I forget. Okay. Everybody wanted
him to win the poor bastard.
He's down there and they'd
taken like the, the,
the warmup lap or whatever. And uh,
not even the warmup lap.
They just going around,
getting ready to get into positions just
to do the warmup lap and his car gets
stuck in sixth gear. We've all been
there, right the side of the highway,
except he's got 100,000
people in a fucking zillion
millions of fans around the
world watching this shit.
So they got to push his car and they got
to take out the fucking transmission in
like five minutes. Throw
a new one in there,
try and get it back in the fucking car
before the race starts. That alone,
if they just showed that,
that would've been amazing.
They kind of kept cutting back to
it. I wish they showed more of it.
A long story short, he wasn't able to
get out there until, uh, the second lap.
He was already two laps down.
So that kind of sucked for all the
Australian fans and uh, then his car shit,
the bed halfway through the race,
however, so the race fucking starts.
All right.
I think Lewis Hamilton had the pole
and then Sebastian Federal, um,
for Ferrari was in second place and Lewis
had a great start and he was out front
and I go, wow, I guess that's it.
I guess the Mercedes are
gonna win it this year. Right.
So they get about 20 laps
in and Lewis Hamilton pits,
it's one of these races,
it's like 57 laps and the announcers were
saying that they were going to pit one
time and it's all when you pit
and blah blah blah, blah blah.
So all this shit is
becoming fascinating to me.
So Lewis Hamilton goes into Pitt,
right? Sebastian Vettel was,
I don't know how far behind,
couple seconds behind he
decides to stay out there.
So the whole time when Lewis
was out there in first place,
Sebastian's behind him. All right.
So Louis is driving in the clean air.
It's like, you know, if you want
to fucking on a lake and you bring,
it's just still water. You could,
you could go way faster and you boat as
opposed to if the water was all fucking
choppy, you got to go slower
than, it's the same thing,
except it's what's with air.
I'm just saying this for everybody else
out there who's dumb like me in the fact
that air is invisible,
you don't understand it.
So no matter what this guy's
doing, Sebastian Vettel,
he can only get so close to a,
to Lewis Hamilton because all
the air coming off of him,
and I guess the tires are bigger this
year, which causes more turbulence.
It would actually,
he's going to use more fuel and chew up
more of his tires if he gets too close
to him, which is really fucking, I dunno,
I don't know if that's
a good or a bad thing.
So Hamilton was having problems
with the tire. He pits early.
So the Ferrari team takes a
gamble and says, fuck this.
We're going to stay out there.
So Sebastian now is in first
place driving into clean air.
He's got the nice smooth lake.
He's bringing the boat across,
except it's a car and it's going
through air. He's still with me.
And he stays out there
for one lap and they go,
he's definitely gonna come in for
the second lap. Meanwhile, um,
Lewis Hamilton came right back out
of the pits and then was, you know,
technically in fourth
place, but he's, you know,
but he already pitted the other two
guys in front of them at the pit.
And so does the other guy. So technically
it's like he's still in first place,
but now he's driving in
dirty air back there.
So Sebastian's flying around the track,
he goes around a second time and,
you know, the tires are getting chewed up.
He's driving like a fucking maniac and
the d comes around a third time and
they're like, he's not gonna, he's
not gonna fucking stay out there.
He stayed out there again and
now basically it was like,
this was the most exciting part of
it because this is the fucking race.
So basically what he's trying to do,
he's trying to get out so far ahead
that he has time to pit when he goes in,
get his tires and get back out on
the track in front of fucking, uh,
Lewis Hamilton. It was
like a fucking movie.
He pulls in his fourth
time around, comes in,
they fucking take the tires. You've got
to go so fucking slow too now. And he,
he got to slow down to like, like you're
driving a Prius when you're in there.
And as he's slowing down this
show and Lewis is coming around,
he's coming around, he's coming
around, he gets the tires,
fucking Sebastian's coming out.
It's like a fucking action movie.
And it was literally,
he just Sebastian, uh,
for Ferrari just get out in front of Lewis
Hamilton. And then that was the race.
He saw the Mercedes guy slammed his
hand down on it. The guy in the pits,
right? They had fucking guy, right.
The guy goes the eyes wide shut illuminati
parties at the end of the fucking
race right there. Probably on
some yacht that's like invisible,
like the air that they
drive through. Right.
He fucking slammed his hand down like
medium and then fucking slammed it down a
second time. And right there I was like,
this guy knows this fucking
race is over. And that was it.
Ferrari won the first race, you know,
backing up their lack of shit talk.
They were real quiet in the off season.
So, uh, I was actually really, you know,
I like the way my, I'm one
of those guys, I like both,
both team proceedings and Ferrari. I mean,
I don't know how you get mad at either
one of them, the fucking beautiful,
amazing cars that they've built all
this fucking, uh, over the years.
So I'm just happy that this seems like
there's going to be competition and if it
can be as exciting as that,
um, for the whole season,
uh, I think, um, maybe some more you
guys can get into it. Like I did,
I believe the next races
in China, in Indochino,
in China. Um, that's gonna
be the next one. But I was,
I was thrilled with the race. Um,
I don't know how many F1
fans listen to this shit. Uh,
I'd love to hear your thoughts
on it. Um, all right. What else?
What else does Celtics one,
the Celtics are technically
in first place right now,
but we got two games at
hands. We've one more,
one more game and lost one more
game than, um, the Cavaliers. But,
uh, I mean I don't, I don't see them,
not the Cavaliers not getting the number
one seed, let's say get real enough.
I don't know if somebody gets fucking
hurt or some shit like that. All right,
last announcement and then
I'm going to read the, uh,
your fucking emails for the week are in
my youtube channel that I'm slowly but
surely building up. All
right. I'm gonna. Um,
I'm gradually just transitioning
to the fucking Internet here.
My whole career is just going to be on
the Internet of the Internet other than
my live dates and f is for family
because everything else is drying up.
So my youtube channel, which I'm, I'm
serious about building up with content.
Um, I actually hired a,
a, an animator and, um,
hired a couple of people to start making
videos and putting content up there.
I'm going to be doing tours
of every city that I go to.
Now I'm bringing those things
back. Uh, I'm actually considering,
um, bringing on this guy that does drum
covers that looks like me, but you know,
isn't me, but maybe it's me. Um, so
anyways, what do we got here? Uh,
on Tuesday, the first
video from Alan Pailin,
pronounced Pailin on the
official podcast channel,
Alan Pale and is the guy
who edited it together. Um,
remember that one when I commentate
commentated basketball. Um,
he's the guy who did that. So,
um, we're going to have new, uh,
videos from him every
single week. Um, my, uh,
youtube page is
youtube.com/user/ it's backslash,
you know,
the one that starts further away and then
comes in towards you like a flare chop
. Um,
youtube.com backslash user
backslash Monday morning podcast.
Please subscribe to the
channel, check it out, and, um,
I'm going to start making some
videos and that type of shit. Um,
I don't know that I'll have a video tape
that podcast cause it's just me laying
here right now I'm wearing a tee
shirt. Pajama bottoms and slippers.
How interesting is that going
to be? And I, every time I,
whenever I saw radio shows
videotaped, they just,
something happened where it was boring.
I liked the fact that like podcast,
it's just like radio on the fact that
you, you, you're doing shit right now.
You drive it home from work. You're
on the fucking elliptical. You know,
you're pouring yourself a drink,
you cleaning the house whenever you're
doing whatever the fuck it is you do and
you can do other shit, right?
All of a sudden it's videotape you feel
you've got to watch somebody's talking
into a microphone. I don't get it. All
right, here we go. Internet privacy.
Everybody. Uh Hey Billy
thought you might like this.
A private Internet access provider took
out a full page ad in the New York Times
calling up 50 senators
who voted to monitor,
monitor the public's internet
activity for financial gain.
What people care a lot
about their public image.
And I think this should be done more
to combat assholes. Let me call,
let me click on this thing. I can't click
on it because I'm not on the Internet.
Hang on, let me try and find this
here. I gotta see who the cons are.
Who are the cons that signed
to the onto this. Alright,
we are the cons. We don't give
a shit. All right. Hello world.
These are the 50 senators who monitor,
who voted to monitor your internet
activity. Now Jesus Christ.
I can't read on the too fucking small.
Okay.
All right.
Oh Jesus. Jesus. What
are they all Republicans,
dude, the way they vote, man.
Cause it was probably something
else that was pro conservative.
That's the only reason why
that fucking Democrats didn't
so fucking and McCoys. It's
basically they're all Republicans
representative from Tennessee.
Alexander representative from Wyoming.
Barrasso blunt from Missouri.
Boozman from Arkansas burn from North
Carolina. You fucking piece of shit.
Okay.
Ruining the name. Kaputo from West
Virginia. Cassie from Louisiana.
Car from, from Mississippi.
Collins from Maine.
Corker from Tennessee. You
know what? I'm just going,
I'm going to just retweet this fucking
picture. Jesus Christ, Republicans,
all Republicans
cruise from Texas, Crappo from
Idaho, some element names,
Danes from Montana,
another one from Wyoming,
NZ from Wyoming earns from
Iowa. This is all of this shit,
all that. Rubio from
Florida, Perdue from Georgia,
Portman from Ohio. This is all like,
this is all saying it's fake news.
It's all fake news. Do you
know it's basically, um,
you know whose kid new news is?
It's propaganda. It's bullshit.
It's bullshit. But what they want
is their bullshit in your brain.
That's what they want.
So what they want to do is gradually take
control of this shit and they're gonna
make fake news. Basically your
opinion of what's going on.
They're going to make that
like illegal to do. Um,
and they're probably looking over
at China going like, Hey China,
how the fuck did you do this? And
China's going like, all right,
this is how we did it. So
they gradually do that.
Much like the Nazis were
looking at us going like, hey,
how did you do that shit
to the native Americans?
Because we want to do that to the
Jews. Now we're going to do that.
Probably what? Look it, I bet.
I bet the fucking hire rub 1% cuts the
people who make profit off a war and
everybody's misery.
I bet they are envious of the Internet in,
in Red China.
The way you know Uri is
envious when somebody drives
down the street by you in a
fucking Ferrari, you
know, I dunno. Alright,
well I'm, I'm good for that
person that put that up there.
Um, that's fucking disgusting. I
wonder what was linked to it though.
You know what I mean? Cause
it's never just in defensive,
all of those fucking people.
It's never just one thing,
which is another bullshit thing. You
know, when, when they vote for something,
they shouldn't just be one thing.
Should we or should we not vote for solar
power? It should just be about that.
But then they tag all this other shit
onto it, onto the bill, which is fucking,
that's how they get everything through.
And then it's always like, yeah,
you know, something completely fucked up.
And then when that person goes
to run for office, you know,
they voted for the bill because they're
into solar power. But then the, the,
the thing that they, the appendix that
they put onto it, they can be like,
this guy doesn't take, kids should have
ice fleet. They voted against that.
It's like, no, I voted for alternative
sources of energy to bankrupt the,
uh, the terrorist terrace. Um,
all right. Bullying manager,
dear bill, about a month ago,
a lady dairy Queen Manager in Missouri
was charged for involuntary manslaughter.
What did she get? The guy in ice cream,
headache pill. She did keep eating
ice cream. Then I'll blow you.
The guy fell for it and he stuck his
hand under the fucking smoothie machine.
The soft serve there.
All right. Allegedly,
the dairy queen manager was a
dick to one of its employees,
uh, filled with name, calling
and belittling day after day.
Is it a great to see women getting
like positions of power and just acting
exactly is fucking ridiculous
as men, you know, most,
most people can not handle a position
of power. I mean, look at me.
Look at the power I
have with this podcast.
I don't have the decency to put on
pants. I mean pajamas and slippers.
I am part of the problem.
Um, one incident report lead,
the manager threw a burger on the floor
after he made it incorrectly and then
made the 17 year old clean it up.
The kid was also a victim of
bullying at school as well. Um,
none of this is going to justify this
kid harming this. This boss, you,
you quit the job, uh,
but voiced most of the
bullying but foist most.
That doesn't make sense. But
most of the bullying happened,
happened at work.
What happened to this person who wrote
the sentence they wrote but voiced most
of the bullying happening
at work and singling,
singling out his boss, his boss. Okay,
well eventually the kid ended
up shooting himself in the head.
Oh boy. He did not see that coming.
Yes, I know. It's a sad story that Oh,
that happens too often. Does it,
do a lot of people get bullied at dairy
queen and then blow their brains out?
I thought that was a happy place.
Oh, they've got soft serve ice cream.
What could go wrong?
But the town wanted to hold
somebody responsible for a suicide.
The authorities air quote investigated
and interviewed people and his stories of
being teased and made fun of where
retold the cops ultimately came to the
conclusion that his dairy queen boss was
the reason the kid is dead now by Jesus
Christ. Wait a minute. Hey, that's
a little bit of an overreach.
And she was charged with secondary
involuntary manslaughter.
Okay.
After me hearing this story,
is that proper English?
Should it be after I heard
this story after for me,
after hearing this story,
I'm waiting for somebody on TV to state
these. The obvious, this is bullshit.
How can you blame someone for
another person killing themselves?
It's not my fault. How other
people handled my insults.
You've been called Billy fat tits.
How many times? Well, first of all,
I'm not 17. All right. Um,
I think enough bullying
can drive somebody to it.
It depends on how it is and how
fragile somebody is, but uh,
there's just so many fucking variables
involved. Like, what had the person,
let's say this person was
a bully at dairy queen,
like what happened to them as a kid
that made them the way they are?
How old is this person?
Because, um, for me,
I just feel that, I honestly
believe that, you know,
people in their twenties, for
the most part, it's just, it's,
that is the most purest form of the
direct results of the parents that you had
is now you're out in the world. They're
not there to be like, hey, you know,
knock it off. You know,
and you have to make decisions for
yourself and you go around. Like,
I know when I was in my twenties, I took,
without realizing it, I was taking my,
everybody takes a childhood out
on people in their twenties,
cause you don't know what the fuck you
doing. So hopefully you had a good one.
So you take in and out on people is, um,
is you're actually a nice
person like Pete Holmes,
his character on crashing, by the way,
I fucking love that show. Um, TJ Miller,
um, rd Lang and I believe the
guy's name is George Bazell. Uh,
I watched the first three fucking
episodes and they were killing me.
And their interaction with Pete's
character is great and I can't wait.
I love Pete Holmes.
I cannot wait to break his balls about
his character on that show though.
I really gonna break his balls like
Pete. Is that how you see yourself?
I'm just a nice guy who tries to
do nice things. It's like Pete,
you're a fucking lunatic.
Just like the rest of us.
Um, anyways, oh, I can't wait to, I, they,
one of my favorite things in this business
is teasing him cause he can fucking
take it. But a, you gotta
check out crashing. Uh, John
Apatow, uh, Pete Holmes,
uh, Joey Roses, Joe to Rosa, uh,
rode on the show to a Mike Birbiglia,
I believe, wrote on the show.
There's a bunch of people, a comics
and everything and comics on it.
I saw agree a bunch, dove Davidoff
all these comics, Marina Franklin.
It's just fucking them.
It's a such an amazing show.
Cause I remember when
he came to New York, um,
as that wide eyed kid and I'd
actually worked with him. And, uh,
this comedy club in Peoria,
Illinois. That doesn't exist anymore.
I worked with him at Brewster's when
he was still married. I believe.
Maybe he'd just gotten divorced.
I can't fucking remember.
I've told this story before. We
went to go see the ring and we,
and we were the only two people in
the movie theater and I hate that.
That's that, that is the detail
because that sounds fake.
That's the only time that it's
ever happened. We walked in,
it was a shitty movie theater.
We were two comedians.
It was the middle of the fucking,
there was like two or the afternoon
when we saw the ring on like a Thursday
afternoon and a shitty movie
theater. And I swear to God,
we the only two fucking people there. Um,
that movie stayed with me certain
with Blair, which stayed with me.
That one stayed with me. Um,
some of them just too, just,
they just fucking creep me
out and they stay with me. Um,
for whatever reason, Jordan peals movie
when that, that guy comes running,
when the kids smoking the cigarette and
then the guy comes fucking just run it
up full speed at Adam.
That fucked with me.
That's for whatever reason that
fucking stayed with me. Um, anyways,
there's like shit I think about
when I go to my car at night,
even though I know it's not real.
I just think about what if that fucking
dude just came running just like that at
the last second. Made a right
turn in front of me. Um,
anyways, how the fuck did I
get onto all of that shit?
Talking about this poor kid who
killed himself. Um, anyways,
he can send that throwing.
Uh, okay. What did he say?
You've been called Billy fat tits.
How many times and by how many
peoples you kill yourself.
Over half of your listeners will
go to jail. How is this a law?
How many times can you call somebody fat
before it's against the law and can we
stop saying bullying? It's just being
teased and made fun of. That's not true,
man. That isn't, that's
not true. That's not true.
It depends on the level and it
depends on the intent. I'm in,
all of this shit will be really hard
to prove, but like, you know, there's,
what it is, sir, is you have to have
empathy here. And what I'm guessing is,
is that you are more the person
teasing than getting teased.
Um,
and maybe you are a little bit more of
a stronger person the same way somebody
else might've just been better at math
than you. Um, I know looking back,
you know, in my high school, I
know that there was, uh, you know,
there was kids that got
it really fucking bad,
really bad and uh, you know, one of them,
you know, killed himself a few years
later. And I remember thinking back,
I don't know what it was based on,
but certainly did not have
a good experience in high
school the last couple of
years.
And it's one of those things because
kids are kids and they don't,
they don't understand it. Um,
it's a really common extinct.
But I would say at this kid
was also bullied at school.
And then if this person was
a content at dairy queen,
I mean it's sort of an amalgam of all of
that. And then also the personalities.
People are born, they're
just really sensitive,
shy people and uh, they
don't know how to handle it.
And if you're prone to depression,
shit, I imagine that, you know,
that sort of the perfect storm. So, um,
anyways, he goes,
they throw this bullying word around
like it's an epidemic sweeping all these
heartless millennials. Uh, we've
all been made fun of before.
We've all been called names ever
since we were little kids. Um,
you sound like an older person
like me and you just doing the day.
These kids today, these
millennials and they'll make God,
they're fragile little flowers and
they're not all like that dude.
You think they still net them mean kid.
You still don't think there's this,
you know, the big guy
just fucking beaten on.
There's always going to be the bigger
kid beating on the younger kids,
the smaller kids or whatever.
Um, we need to let this continue.
It builds character. If you
were always given a trophy,
you're all over the map here.
Dude. It only told compliments you,
you wouldn't be a comedian. Um,
no. Now you speaking for me,
you would still be working in the carpeted
area discussing which I never worked
there. Your favorite route
to work in the morning.
All I'm saying is that we're all becoming
weak pussies because of laws like this
and nobody's addressing it.
But you can bill with your soon
to be Emmy winning podcast.
You can champion this cause
for all hours sake or whatever.
I hope to see important suit. Thanks.
I have to be honest with you sir.
All right. I think, uh,
the true sign of maturity,
aside from on one side,
being able to take a good ribbing and,
and learning how to have more of a sense
of humor by yourself and also learning
that whatever's happening today is
not the end of the fucking world.
And that, you know, it's probably kids
listening right now. They get bullied.
This is the thing, all of that shit. It's,
you're not going to see any of those
fucking people ever again after high
school.
And your whole fucking life is going to
be determined by you and the decisions
you make, and you have
100% control over that. So,
um, you know,
and I think a lot of times people get
bullied up the side from the fact that
they're, that they're just smaller,
weaker. They just seem like targets.
I think, you know, sometimes when
people see somebody that's talented, um,
they'll go after him and, uh,
so you've gotta make sure that you
kind of push all that shit away.
But the other side, I think that really
shows that you're mature. His, uh,
his empathy, you know what I
mean? Uh, it certainly helps.
Like, uh, I mean, I can think it's
easy to do that. The rent that you did,
I understand there's a lot of truth in
some of the shit that he's saying, but,
um, you know, it's not all just like,
oh, I'll learn how to fucking take it.
You fucking pussy stop wearing a
helmet when you ride bicycles and shit.
And I'm guilty of saying stuff like that.
I understand where you're coming from,
but like a, you know, so
what, what is, what, what,
why do you think this kid killed
himself? You know what I mean?
Do you think if that
shit wasn't happening,
the kids still would have made it's
a possibility on our own fit kid had
clinical depression? I have no idea.
But I agree with you to try
from what you've written
for the sentences where the [inaudible]
was spelled correctly. Uh, it
seems like that kid was just having
a miserable experience. I mean,
I can't imagine if you were
getting bullied all day at
school and then you'd go,
okay, well now I'm going to get a job.
This might be a ray of light to
what the future is going to be,
where I'll be at work and maybe people
are nicer and then it just becomes
somebody else screaming
at you. Um, you know,
when you're 17 years old, if it sucks at
school and it sucks at the dairy queen,
you work at that is your world and, uh,
you don't have an ability to step out
of it and you can downward spiral.
Like once again, I don't think that
they should put it all on this person,
but that's a a, it's a
fucking terrible story. Um,
but I,
I don't think this backlash to the two
to political correctness to then go the
other fucking go the all the way back
once again to what caused political
correctness. All you fucking guys
ain't pull you bootstrapped up.
Stop being a fucking pussy.
You fucking millennial flour.
It's guys like you that are fucking
ranting against fucking political
correctness. It's constant. Like you
that created a political correctness,
you know, white guys
that tell it like it is,
is there anything worse than
the white guy that I know.
I always say that I fucking, that's,
that is, to me, that is the most boring
fucking mindset you could possibly
have. Hey, I'm a white guy.
Everything's set up for me.
Let me tell you who, you know,
just not have the advantages that I
have, why you need the toughen up.
You know, as I slept in my
bunk bed and my Culdesac,
those were the years that I really
became a tough guy. Um, anyways, so,
yeah, I mean I, that's just a terrible
story. I, I, I, I hope that, you know,
something good can come out of it cause
that's, you know, it's very rare that,
you know, you bring up an ice cream
store and something like that happens.
I was all excited. You know, I
love fucking dairy queen. You know,
my wife loves dairy queen. We are
dairy queen people, uh, cleaning up.
All right, dear bill t ability red
faced in, um, I'm 52 years old.
Congratulations.
Most people don't live that long or a
lot of people don't make it that far. Uh,
I'm 52 years old, but a life of
drinking has made me look 62.
I still drink and I smoke weed
all day. Jesus guys going hard.
You drink and you smoke weed all day.
I wasn't there for my kids growing up.
They had to go through a lot because
of my mine and my wife's addiction
problems. JZ. I imagine they did. Uh,
let's say Jesus is two depressing ones
in a row. What does this doctor, Phil,
you need to stop drinking, smoking,
Wade and pay attention to your
children. Crowd goes crazy.
Another episode in the can and he gets
more syndication money and then that
fucking drunk walks out the door,
continues to do what the fuck he's doing.
And Dr Phil Looks Great. Uh, let's
just say the fact that they turned out,
let's just face the fact that they,
the way they turned out
has nothing to do with me.
I take no credit for the
people they are today. Well,
nor should you with the exception
of any lingering anxiety. I May,
I may have caused them.
I mean if you're the kind of dad
that you're saying you were, yeah,
you kind of own up to it, which is good
I guess. Unless you're doing that like,
so everybody goes, no, no, you
are actually, you're good. Dad.
All depends on what your,
your reasoning is. Um,
I don't live close to my daughters,
but I am starting to miss them.
Um, I feel like they'd be better
without me at this point. Nah,
I'm at a fork in the road.
I can either clean up and realize that
my life isn't over set my phone buzzing.
Oh, and he spills his first glass
of water the day. All right.
I can fucking call this back in a
minute. Um, all right. Where am I? Um,
I can either clean up and realize that
my life isn't over and then I may have
the grandchildren one day that I want to
have a relationship with or just enjoy
my responsibility. Less
life, uh, responsibility,
less life until I die. That
sounds morbid in the answer.
May seem more obvious to someone else,
but there was a good chance my kids
won't care either way at this point.
And I don't want to disrupt
them by being the annoying, hey,
can I come back into your life person
quitting won't be easy and I'm trying to
weigh my options. What should I do? A,
you should get clean and sober
and own up to everything.
Apologize to your kids and then understand
that it's your kid's choice whether
they want you back in
their life or not. And uh,
that's what they decide that they don't.
You have to be a man about it and I
wouldn't pao and go back to drinking and
smoking. Um,
you can totally clean your life up and
you can put years back on the odometer,
you know, or you can be dead in 10
years. I mean, it's up to you. I mean,
it's pretty a pretty easy, easy choice.
But I would say the first thing you
should do is try to get help and, um,
I dunno, I got to tell you, dude, not
drinking and all that type of stuff.
You feel like you feel like
1 million bucks, you know,
four days of not drinking alone.
When you wake up in the morning,
you're going to feel 20 years younger,
you know? So, uh, I don't know.
You want to keep feeling
like shit. It's gonna.
That's gonna be a brutal death bed dude.
Just sitting there waiting
for someone to show up,
hoping someone's going to show up. You
don't want that man. You're only 52.
You know, you got a lot of years left.
You got a quarter of
a century left if you,
if you eat right in a exercise.
And all of that type of stuff. So,
you know, it's up to you,
man. You're an adult.
I hope you make a positive choice.
Jesus Christ. All Right, yogurt.
Does anybody die in this one? Um, maybe
it's more than you want to bother,
but it's really easy to make your own
yogurt. Uh, then you know what's in it.
I'm not going to down going
to load you down with links,
but this is a pretty decent start. Yeah.
And they send me this fucking
video of this woman immediately.
I'm envious of her cha of her kitchen
and the fact that she gets us,
she can speak more than one language cause
I think that's cool as shit. But, uh,
she's making yogurt and one of the things,
one of the ingredients she
goes is very simple yogurt.
One of the ingredients she makes,
one of the ingredients
to her yogurt is yogurt.
I'm going to show you how to make
chicken. All right? Get Salt and pepper,
put it in a ball and then go to
the store and buy some chicken.
Some already made chicken. I don't
get it. I don't get that video. Um,
I'm fine with just the Greek
yogurt, probiotic. It tastes
fucking weird as shit.
The plain stuff. And after a while you're
going addicted to and you love it. So,
um, I appreciate it. I will post the
link. It's a great fucking steal.
I love about that stove.
It's got four burners and then it's
got the griddle in the middle. Oh,
I love that. Oh, I want that
stove. So fucking bed. All right.
Fun Car to drive Billy sports car. Uh,
you were talking about cars on Thursday.
The most fun car I ever drove
was a 1968 Alpha Romeo sedan.
Not this spider. Google it.
Short throw, manual shift.
My favorite fucking thing
ever handles greats. Um, yeah,
I actually, um, I actually
looked up the car though.
There was only youtube videos, pictures
of them. Nobody had this sedan.
I'll tell you one of the best,
most fun shifting cars I ever
drove was my older brother had a,
had like a 1981,
two door Toyota Tercel for
speed and that fucking thing.
It was so tight it would do, you had
to move that fucking thing. Like,
I swear to God,
like an inch and a half and you
were in another gear and uh,
even though it was a four cylinder
by today's standards, you know,
it was a pretty goofy looking
car, sand high up off in shit.
But it was funniest shit to drive. We
used to have these jobs with, you know,
we had paper routes from the time we
were in third grade right up til ninth
grade.
And then when we got our licenses we
just delivered bigger routes and we drove
around beating the shit out of our cars
and that was the most fun car to drive
cause you could stack it the back
seat up with all the papers and um,
and dude it was a Toyota and that's when
Toyota was really competing with the
American shit. And um, the only
way that they were going to get it.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Are you fucking kidding me too?
This is how fucked up my houses.
I just spilled water and I was just like,
you know what? On the hardwood floors,
I'm going to finish the podcast.
I'm almost done. I got to take.
I can't believe this just happened and
I'm thinking that's the fucking water.
It's going to be on the floor.
It's just going to be a puddle.
This is what just happened. I
just looked down at the floor.
I feel I spilled a full glass
of water. It's all gone.
It's not there anymore. Sorry.
I put the headphones back on
the fuck out of here.
The floor isn't even wet.
This is what happens and this
is only one part of my house.
If the house is settled so much.
My house is 94 years old this year.
It's settled so much that I swear to God,
the water rolled down the
hill and the baseboard.
This is space between the floor ports
in the baseboard and it just rolled into
the cracks and disappeared.
This can't be fucking happen
on fucking believable.
Well, I've got it now. I'm
wondering where did that go?
Is the ceiling below now? Gonna
have all watermarks on it.
I don't think that's enough water
to do it, dude. I'm telling you.
I'm telling you right fucking now. Okay.
The next house I get
is going to be fucking,
if it's an old house, it's going to be,
we looked at one this weekend where we
should we just look into when it would
bullshit. You know what I mean? Um, but
just trying to see what's out there,
what the prices are and that type of shit
do. We looked at one, it was turnkey.
That's what I want. And for all
you people never bought a house.
That means the whole fucking
thing has been redone.
I don't give a fuck that
somebody flipping it.
I don't give a shit that they're trying
to make fucking 500 fucking thousand
dollars in two months. I don't care.
The fact that they're going
to strip it all the way down,
all the way down, all the piping,
the sewer line right out to the
fucking street. Everything's brand new.
That's the house I'm getting.
That's the house I'm getting
and that's the house I'm dying.
And when I died,
the fucking next person can deal
with whatever bullshit I did to it.
I just spilled a full glass of fucking
water and it disappeared like a magic
trick. All right, that's the
podcast. Go fuck yourselves up.
Checking on you on a on
Thursday. Go, Bro. It's.